la décision était attendue ce matin à
l'elysée emmanuel macron a annoncé la
fin de narbonne et d'opérations de lutte
contre le terrorisme au mali manière
d'avancer nous ne pouvons pas rester
engagés militairement aux côtés d'
autorité de fait dont nous ne partageons
ni la stratégie ni les objectifs cachés
c'est la situation à laquelle nous
sommes confrontés aujourd'hui au mali
la france n'était plus la bienvenue au
mali la rue manifestait de plus en plus
ouvertement son hostilité à la
renaissance des soldats de la force
barkan les relations avec la junte
militaire qui avait pris le pouvoir en
2020 était exécrable
il n'y aura donc plus aucune base
française dans le pays
un retrait accueilli avec amertume par
cette femme son frère damien noblet
était l'un des 53 soldats tués en
actions au mali j'ai pas le sentiment
qu'ils soient morts pour rien mais
aujourd'hui on a un peu le sentiment
d'un départ forcé un peu précipité et
est ce que des engagements c'est un
constat c'est un constat d'échec
un échec réfutée par emmanuel macron
2500 à 3000 hommes vont se redéployer
ailleurs vers les états d'afrique de
l'ouest là où la menace djihadiste se
fait de plus en plus pressante
il ya quelques jours avec l' attaque
contre des gardes-forestiers au nord du
bénin est d'ailleurs dans lequel un
français a été tué mais dans la foulée
quarante huit heures après le groupe
terroriste a été neutralisée une
quarantaine de djihadistes ont été
neutralisés et c'est vers ce type
d'opération que nous allons continuer le
départ des troupes françaises au mali va
prendre du temps de 4 à 6 mois
actuellement 2400 soldats sont sur place